hello everyone how's everybody doing
welcome to
rational science today we're going to
talk about this gentleman
his name is juan maldasena he's a
compatriot of mine he's uh
my fellow countrymen and uh
mentioned him the other day he's born a
little farther north than me in buenos
aires
anyways uh he works as a string theorist
at the um at the new jersey the
princeton
institute for advanced studies ias okay
and one of the things i want you to keep
in mind today is you know here you have
the operating funds for the institute of
advanced study
they receive nine percent of their
budget from government agencies
that means taxes you're paying maybe
around 10
of their operating funds and so one of
the things you have to keep in mind is
whether we want to support such a thing
and he's uh practicing catholic okay
in fact he received an award from the
society of catholic
scientists one of their goals is similar
to the john templeton foundations
integrate the world of science and
religion in 2018
st albert award of the society of
catholic scientists
was given to juan martin maldasena in
recognition of his exceptional
contributions to fundamental physics
what fundamental physics well we're
talking about string theory
and he's won several awards for that
especially for his paper the one he
published in 1997
which has been referenced over 10 000
times
so he's a popular guy in string theory
okay
and one thing i should mention is you
know in comparison to the two ladies and
two fellows who i
covered in the last couple weeks uh you
know those are science
communicators mr maldison is a little
more than just a
science communicator he's well versed in
the mathematics
of string theory so if you want to learn
strength he's one of those
top honchos that you really want to get
involved with you know
so he's uh he's quite versed in in the
in the subject matter that he teaches
okay
that's one of the things that you have
to keep in mind so here i'm going to be
analyzing
one of the top honchos okay there's no
doubt about it okay
okay but uh i have to begin with some
criticism
of mr maldacena and that's because he
made this comment one of his videos he
says if you remove the air
everything would fall in the same way
this is something that galileo
discovered
now galileo did not discover that i've
covered this in the past and i'm gonna
emphasize it today even before galileo
galileo was only 22 years old when this
gentleman
from netherlands his name is simon
steven
he writes the book he publishes when
galileo was only 22 years old
the experience against aristotle is the
following let us take as the very
learned mr
groot most industrious investigator of
the secrets of nature
and myself have done two spheres of lead
the one ten times larger and heavier
than the other and drop them together
from a height of 30 feet
onto a board or something on which they
give a perceptible sound
so mr steven already figured out that
aristotle
had a problem he already did the
experiment he did it from the tower of
the new church city and death
he might say okay but that's a close
call because you know if galileo was 22
well he could have
maybe done it around the same time okay
certainly he didn't write about it at
the same time so mr tavern gets
credit there but let's go further uh
galileo's replaced in 1592 he replaced
uh as the chair of the mathematics
department at the university of padua
he replaced uh mr giuseppe moletti
also known as moleto okay and mr moletti
ten years before steven now we're
talking about galileo being
12 years old okay already wrote in his
book
the same thing that he uh did the
experience
he dropped these two balls so and uh
obviously galileo uh knew molety because
he replaced them at the university of
podwar and i think he was a student of
molety as well
so he got all this stuff from molete in
the best of cases
okay so no galileo isn't the first one
and it's it's a shame that all these
people don't do a minimum of research
before they spread these myths and just
propagated from decade to decade from
generation to generation
you know and likewise you know we're
going to go a couple
more examples one of them is that
descartes rene descartes the french guy
he's sometimes credited with having come
up with a wave
theory of light no never happened never
will okay
uh um descartes
he didn't write if you look at his book
you know you won't especially on
uh optics you won't find any mention of
wave or
pressure for that matter you won't find
those words in there and the fella who
wrote to him was thomas hobbes
from england right and they would write
back and forth
and also thomas hobbs wrote another
treaty on uh
treaties on uh on optics
neither one mentions waves as far as i'm
concerned unless someone shows me
something different
the way the guy who came up with the
wave nature of light is
thomas uh robert hook uh he wrote a book
uh
in 1665 he which he published in 1665
micrographia in there no doubt about
you'll find the word wave many times
he's the first guy who really mentions
the wave
which is later taken by christian
heightened huggins in
his treaties on light he develops it in
in a more formal manner but until then
you know we have to give credit to
uh robert hook okay now um
you know one of the reasons galileo
became famous is because newton
mentions and analyzes galileo and works
using galileo as his foundation i don't
think newton was aware of stefan at all
i don't know if he was or not because
you're talking about a generation
earlier
uh quite a bit of a generation almost uh
you know one guy was born 100 years
before the other so you know there was a
big difference there
anyways i think that all these uh
professors they should not propagate the
myth
that galileo discovered that tube
awaits um two different weights fall at
the same time
on the ground and that he did the trick
from the what
the tower pizza no
i don't think maybe he did one of his
students mentions many years after that
uh
galileo did throw a couple stones or
something from the tower of pisa
but i don't think it there's no real uh
evidence in the writing in you know
written evidence that that ever happened
even from galileo or from anybody else
okay um
so we have a problem uh with uh string
theory
and uh again i have a question is
whether you want to support any
investigation any study of strength
theory that's what i'm gonna argue today
okay how do we get into strength theory
well
we have a problem with quantum mechanics
that quantum mechanics does not
incorporate gravity
and in fact there were a couple other
problems not only gravity we have
problems
uh in quantum mechanics understanding
almost anything uh as mr
several them uh one is mr bohr the other
one mr feynman
even leonard suskin
all of them say the same thing you
cannot imagine quantum mechanics
okay you cannot try to make sense of it
try to uh bohr said it you cannot even
try to illustrate if you try to
illustrate it well you have a mental
problem means you didn't understand
squat
okay so you can't go in there and try to
illustrate can't
not try to visualize what's happening in
there under quantum mechanics
okay and so how do we get into that draw
i mean if you cannot imagine how can
they say that quantum mechanics has been
proven to be more or less correct
if uh you cannot even imagine quantum
mechanics so we have a
something to resolve there okay that's
all i'm saying here
and here's the problem with one of the
problems in uh
quantum mechanics is the slit experiment
or as mr finance says
you know it contains the essence of
what the problems are in quantum
mechanics you know you have either
whether you use particles or you use
waves
and you send them through two slits you
get these fringes on the wall on the
other side of the
partition that's got the two uh slits
and you would think that you know if you
throw particles you know try to throwing
balls through two slits and you'll get
uh paintballs or whatever you know
you'll you'll get the markings but
there'll be two straight lines you won't
get fringes you won't get many
as you see there in the picture you
won't see many uh lines
and with water uh you can uh simulate
water waves
but then the question there is why do
the water droplets the the h2os you know
the molecules
why do they spread apart after going
after the sled well they push each other
away
that's why they they spread out and then
they interfere with each other
how do you explain that uh with light is
light
is is water a good um analogy
for light for photons
so that's one of the things you got to
think about the other one is
entanglement okay and here it is
this thing comes up there
okay and that's uh you have two
particles million
miles away from each other uh one goes
positive the other one instantly turns
negative or vice versa or windows
clockwise the other one counterclockwise
uh they change colors whatever they take
like opposite effects of each other
their charges change etc
and how you do that with quantum
mechanics how can you explain that with
quantum mechanics
because what's between them is there a
connection a physical connection
and so quantum says no there is no
physical uh connection and what they do
is use
information they say well the
information is transferred
faster than the speed of light yeah when
you talk about concepts yeah you can do
that very easily the question can you do
this with objects
and no they can't quantum can't explain
that with
objects with things that's where the
problem is and the only
answer that they have for that is well
father universe and mother nature work a
little different than
the minds of humans so their rationality
is not the same as
our rationality and my answer to that is
well does father universe and mother
nature
does their rationality match your
rationality the one you're trying to
you know shove down my throat you're
saying that this is your interpretation
based on your
equations and you're saying you
represent father
universe and mother nature that you know
exactly how they run the universe
or nature and that i'm wrong
because i rely on intuition whereas you
rely on mathematics
well i don't know i don't know if mother
nature went to college and learned
you know trigonometry or
algebra or calculus you know i mean
you have two stones the earth and mars
and one tugs on the other we know that's
true it's a fact
uh certainly the earth tugs on the moon
and it's only two stones how difficult
can that be i mean
do we have to go to college and do a lot
of uh
you know integration and calculate
derivatives
to find out what how uh the the earth
keeps the moon faithful to it why the
moon doesn't fly out of the solar system
so
uh these are things that this is the
focus that we're giving all this
okay and this is the problem the problem
comes here in quantum mechanics
and in mathematical physics in general
uh they rely on one-way waves
or they rely on one-way particles which
aren't particles
you know the classical particle the
speck of dust that's not what
quantum has is particles quantum
particle is a magical particle
it's a particle first of all that's not
a particle because it's a point
a zero dimensional point which
represents a number
a value a magnitude an amount that's all
that
little point uh represents because they
can put that into an equation
see they cannot put a tree in an
equation they cannot put a rock in an
equation they cannot put a dog in an
equation
so they have to put the mass of the dog
the length of the tree
the number of seconds the clock measured
instead of putting the clock they can't
put a clock in an equation
so they work with all these um these uh
values that they calculated and that
they measured that's what they're going
to put in there that's their language
the question is if
any of that represents the physical
world from which they derived all that
information okay and again these are all
one-way
mechanisms what do we propose instead
well before that let me just mention
that as a result of that you know they
misconstrued
the uh the light because see
if you show these uh particles on the
left going straight
uh how do you explain the wave nature of
light with that and if you go with the
one on the right where you see the
wave nature mediated by particles
the question is what pushes each
particle up and what pushes
each particle back down again why would
uh these particles oscillate
up and down so right now they don't have
a mediator that they can use for light
whether they use the one-way particles
or the oscillating particles or whether
they use what you see on the upper left
which are just vectors
those are just vectors they have
magnitude and direction because they put
the direction there right
and that's all they are and they have
this mathematical concept that is moving
that's scary okay but this is these are
the things that they're going to give
use to give physical interpretations to
their theories with
okay this is the issue okay so um
as a result they ended up with this with
this uh
quantum atom which is the the planetary
model that mr bohr and mr rutherford
came up with
okay and you can see the electron b
jumps from one energy level as they call
it to another energy level
you can think of those as orbitals as
they also call them okay
and with this they can explain you know
the quantum jump that you see there you
can explain ionization
and they explain electricity which is
what you see on the bottom you know the
electron bead
uh moving from valence level to vason's
level from atom to atom
so you ask them uh okay so electricity
according to use this flow of electron
beads from atom to atom
is that your atom the one that you're
using to
simulate electricity and they say well
no that's not our atom
you know the planetary model has been
debunked gazillions of times
the planetary model is not the atom of
quantum but that's the one they're going
to use for ionization for
the quantum jump for electricity so we
have a contradiction because
they're supposed to use you know
whatever they use they want they have to
use it consistently and they can't say
at the end of their presentation
uh by the way you know that talk that i
just did about electricity
uh forget it because the atom that i
present is not
the real atom not the one we propose
it's not when mother nature uses her
father
uh universe or whoever so we have a
problem because they can't come up and
start with an atom that they're going to
use consistently and then
not deny at the end of their
presentation that's what the problem is
what do we propose in exchange okay here
it is
we propose that all atoms in the
universe are physically
interconnected no one in the last 400
years has proposed
that atoms are physically interconnected
this is the first time we have this 21st
century okay so we have a new proposal
on the table
and that's that all the math that they
did with discrete particles and waves
the waves maybe but particle is
irrelevant
and has no bearing on physics on light
on electricity
on magnetism on gravity has no ref
relevance whatsoever so they did a lot
of calculations they did a lot of
exercises with the uh
integrals and with the derivatives so
what's the point of all that
if they had the wrong or the irrational
because it's not wrong it's just
irrational you can't
make sense of the particle hypothesis
here we're saying
the atoms are interconnected there you
have the 3d model and the 2d model okay
quantum jump they expand and contract
and by doing so they torque
the physical mediator which is a
rope-like dna-like
mechanism a twine pair of anti-parallel
threads there you have it that's that's
the model very simple
how is that rope and the atoms
constructed they're constructed out of
the same thread
okay there's a single thread in all of
the universe let's see if i can
hope you can see that that's let me put
it here
okay there it is that's that's all there
is in the universe
okay just a single thread closed loop
thread
this thread moves around
winds around doesn't move but it winds
around every atom in the universe
which is connected to the next atom
through the electromagnetic ropes
which is made of the same thread paired
points threads
so you go from twine threads to atom to
twine threads to atom and so on down the
line
and there's the construction on the
bottom yeah what you see
and again i put the 3d and the 2d at the
lower left
and you have one thread goes in through
the center of the atom constructs
the proton every thread from every atom
in the universe
is converging upon our proton the other
one goes around and it forms this
encapsulating
membrane okay and that's the atom that's
going to pump back and forth
and torque the rope and torsion is the
fastest thing imaginable
okay so uh it explains the speed of
light for sure why
light is so fast and explains a whole
bunch of other features i'm going to
summarize in a second here but
meanwhile here's the difference between
what mathematical physics and everybody
else proposes discrete particles the
ether
just a bunch of loose particles that
have no relation to each other they just
uh
you have a sandbox essentially and the
sandbox supposedly all the particles
move they're like bunch of bees instead
of like a sandbox that's the way they
treat them
under the rope model every atom in the
universe is physically
connected bound to all others okay
so that's the difference in the two
models we're proposing a new model all
together and obviously it's going to
require
a different set of equations but it uh
has no problem with equations like
maxwell's equations no problem
there it's just when you get into this
magical particles of quantum
that's when you have to look a little
deeper because there they have virtual
particles popping in from the void
you know getting together and forming
nothing and then separating forming
something and so on so they have all
these
little tricks that they use to convince
you that
they're right and that they're rational
okay
so the first thing it answers is uh the
rope model
very easy to show to yourself you know
you don't have to take my word for it
uh proof evidence that's what i'm going
to talk about
here uh you take any rope okay here's a
rope okay
and you count the links like there you
have two links well you torque it some
more
right the more you torque it the more
links you have and each link is shorter
that's the wave equation that you're
seeing there frequency times wavelength
are inversely related so that
if one goes up the other one goes down
that's the equation of a rope
right no one has figured it out in the
last what 400 years since the days of uh
robert hook and christian higgins okay
and um here you can see uh
different uh focus on this okay and when
you look at a prism
okay you shine white light on one end
like newton did some uh many years ago
right
uh what you get on the other end is not
uh wavelengths coming out in one
direction as they say or
particles popping out of there now what
you have is every atom is connected to
every atom in the universe
and the atoms at the edge of the prism
on the right hand side they're connected
to ropes through ropes to other atoms
which are i don't know on the wall or
in the air or wherever and what you have
is as they come out
of the prism what you have is longer
wavelengths on the top
lower wavelengths on the bottom we call
them link links
and that gives you the spectrum from red
to blue and so on
okay so that's the model okay no uh
no traveling particles no traveling
waves especially one way
it's a two-way mechanism so the torsion
travels in both directions to both atoms
simultaneously as they're pumping
torquing the rope okay what does this
answer well for sure what i call the
checklist of light
okay and if quantum can do the same
thing with either the wave or the
particle
they should get an oval for it and light
is so fast because it consists of a
torsion propagating along a helical
dna-like medium that's why little c is
equal to
the inverse relation between frequency
and wavelength
or really link length a photon is
massless because light is mediated by a
tense taut rope-like pair of twined
anti-parallel threads that interconnects
any two atoms
the electric field runs perpendicular to
the magnetic field because the twine
threads on the road can do no other
you know just take any roam you'll see
that one runs 90 degrees to the other
in fact uh when we go into magnetism
that becomes
even more more patently evident
uh a top rope invariably embraces an
imaginary axis you can see the imaginary
axis is running right through a taut
rope at the bottom a light has an
undulatory nature and because of
traveling
and because of traveling transverse
waves not not because of traveling
transverse waves but because a rope
spinning around its axis
exhibits goosebumps moving along its
structurally wavy surface
you can see that at the bottom as well
and amplitude is structural
property attribute of a two-strand rope
okay so
uh this and and several of these are
just the most uh
common properties attributes of a rope
but
uh there are other features that they
have shown about light
that the rope handles very easily
whereas a transverse wave you know it
fails because what is a transverse wave
it's a
flat two-dimensional way it belongs to
uh the days of euclid we're talking
about plane waves here okay
what is a plane wave what what physical
object is that and what they show is
obviously
vectors and they have these vectors
moving sideways
so they're pointing upwards and they're
moving very scary very good scary stuff
okay and so how do we handle
entanglement here you have entanglement
again one particle
affects the other one at a great
distance well with a rope model you have
no problem with action at a distance
whatsoever here you see them side by
side
um if you take one atom that's pumping
torsion waves to another atom
and vice versa right one is clockwise
the other one is counterclockwise as
soon as you turn one around well the
rope can only spin in one direction or
the other
and one of the things that has to be
analyzed here is that you know when
no one has ever considered something
like a rope mediating two atoms
and so now we have to go back and do uh
experiments like uh
the epr experiment which um french guy
did can't remember
uh aspect um ellen aspect did
showing that it is a feature of quantum
mechanics in other words
that when one goes clockwise the other
one goes counterclockwise
instantaneously like if you measure here
and measure there
and yeah and the issue there is very
simple now we have to figure out
that whole experiment again in the
context of the rope model are you
measuring the same rope are you
measuring a parallel rope that's moving
in the opposite or in other words one's
moving clockwise the other one's moving
counterclockwise
see because this is very simple from
from your end see if i can do this right
you know i'm going to turn mine
counterclockwise hopefully your end is
turning clockwise
now let me turn it around okay now mine
is going clockwise and your end should
be moving counterclockwise
no mystery no mystery under the rope
model it's a big problem in quantum
mechanics they can't explain and they
never will with particles because
they're talking about action at a
distance
mediating mediated by spirits
they're back to religion they're saying
that there's no physical object there
between the two atoms but one affects
the other
sounds like religion to me okay
and uh how about the slit experiment
okay well they do it with waves okay
they say there's
interference again they use the analogy
of water waves
a lot of problems with that but a bigger
problem comes with a particle which is
the one they're trying to
get through because otherwise quantum
dies because you won't see waves in the
standard model which you'll see as
particles and so how do you do it with
particles and so they have to come up
with ways of doing it with particles
okay
and so here it is in a nutshell what the
issue is
uh you send a particle it hits the edge
of the window sill you could say of the
slits okay so you have a little slit
there the photon
or the electron whichever one however
you do the test hits the edge
of that window right and bounces inwards
and then you can have you know you can
show interference
from one to the other fine great in fact
uh here we have uh
mr tanomura he was from itachi and
before then there's another claim by mr
gurley uh fellow from
italy and his group and they claimed
they handled one electron at a time when
they did this experiment and you can see
that
they can they film this and they were
able to say to
uh show that one electron at a time hits
the screen
and forms the interference fringes that
you see there
and so uh mr tatamura like mr gertie uh
they both concluded that
obviously an electron is a particle
because it's obviously
it went one electron at a time hitting
the wall or the screen or whatever they
used as a
background there and uh maybe mr
tana morris spoke a little too soon
maybe he jumped the gun
okay why because because of this
see here we have again the quantum atom
and mr tonymor is assuming that
electricity is what you see on the
bottom
a flow of electron beads moving from
atom to atom
and eventually hitting the screen and so
the question is
okay let's accept mr tanomura's uh
explanation
that electron beads move from atom to
atom and he handled one electron at a
time
is he talking about the planetary model
is that is that the atom he's using
uh by default
and he might say well no that's not the
quantum atom so please show me your
quantum atom before you make
an un uh substantiated
statement like that you handle one
electron at a time
how do you know that electrons are beads
that
move around you know inside the atom
okay so we have a different model of the
electron and yes when we apply
schrodinger's equation to our atom
it's a little different it's not a
little bead that's over here and over
there no the
the electron is a membrane
and what uh schrodinger's equation does
is not tell you where you can find the
electron bead it tells you
a location on the membrane
it's a different model and we use the
same equation
but it has a different meaning because
it's in the context of a membrane
which is what chemistry uses anyways
when they do you know uh molecular
bonding and so on okay so
um keep that in mind okay here's uh
the other problem that uh mr tanomor
would run into in all
uh quantum mechanics um because what
they cannot explain is this
and that's that what if we remove the
partition
the slit partition and replace it with a
needle you know we're going to replace
it with
a little needle okay see that
okay so we're going to use the needle
maybe you can see it better there okay
we're gonna use a needle we're gonna
shine
i'll do it with a light because you can
see that okay but let me get this one
out of here for a second
so uh see if i can do that
okay you see the uh the laser pointer
okay laser beam and if i point the laser
beam at the needle
i will also get fringes on the wall in
fact i did the experiment you can find
it in
one of my videos there i did it live and
so what's the issue there the issue
there is that
what uh mr um tony mora and his
colleagues will not be able to explain
essentially is this if i can get this
thing up here
okay if we remove the partition put a
needle
now the what will the uh photons or
electrons bounce against
see there it's bouncing but if we remove
that okay
now the electron has or the photon has
nothing to bounce against and won't come
inwards to
interfere indeed uh
mr uh first let me show you this uh here
we have a tree
okay and you shoot two balls right and
they're gonna interfere with each other
but the one on the right you know should
hit the tree and move outwards
okay there's no way that ball can hit
the edge of the tree and move inwards
which is what quantum is saying is
happening and uh because they have to
interfere like this see
so this is what quantum where a quantum
uses this magic
says well you know uh it turns the
corner like the water waves that turn
the corner well so does the particle
what justification is that how does that
particle hit the edge of the screen and
of the slit and move towards the left
for example in this case right
okay so this is the problem and um in
fact mr tatamura
in his uh diagram shows it look here he
shows that he did it with electrons okay
and what happened he sends the electrons
but he needs an electron by prism
to get the beam to converge otherwise if
he doesn't have that electron
prism biprism then what happens those
lines will go straight and you won't
have interference
so uh whether you use uh particles
or like electrons you know if you use
tennis balls
like he did here you have to have
something that pushes them back in
and that's where he uses the electron
vaporism to focus the beam back in so he
can create the
interference fringes then he claims that
he handled one electron at a time
now no the way he would have shown that
he handles one electron at a time is get
rid of by prism
uh the electron by prism and uh just do
it with electron see if it works that
no the uh the electron beads will well
they won't go around they'll just keep
going and he knows that
that's why they use the bike prism okay
okay so uh yeah again uh mr tatamura
jumped the gun
and this is why he jumped the gun
because he did it with
a gun he thought he was shooting bullets
and the way we explain it is like a
drill
a drill bit we can make holes in the
walls also with drills
so uh we have a different mechanism it's
not shooting bullets it's drilling
okay and for this you need to know what
electricity is
okay because this is the problem these
people say well electricity is the flow
of beads well how do you know it's the
flow of beads uh how did you
prove that or is it just that you
inherit that the
stuff from classical mechanics in the
19th century
okay so uh here's a slit experiment
according to
the rope model what you have is you turn
on the light and when you do
all atoms in the needle are connected
already connected to
all atoms on the screen and in fact they
are connected before you turn the light
on
everything is already connected with
ropes electromagnetic ropes in the
universe every atom is connected to all
others
when you turn on the light what you're
doing is increasing the frequency
of the rope of the you know what you're
doing is again what i showed earlier
you're increasing the torque you have
more uh frequency and others more
links and each link is shorter that
takes
the what was until then dark it takes it
into the visible range
and now as soon as you have it in the
visible range it uh
relays that signal along the ropes that
are connected from the needle to the
partition
everything is connected all you're doing
is turning on something that's already
there
okay and then yes you can create very
simply uh the
interference fringes simply by following
what
has been known so far as uh wave
interference uh both constructive
and destructive so all you have to do is
apply uh the wave notion that they did
but you apply it to the rope
and we're done there's no change there
it's what we're changing is the mediator
we're saying it's a three-dimensional
not a two-dimensional
wave fields which are concepts no we're
talking which are numbers what's a field
field is a bunch of numbers that's all a
field is there's no physical object
called the field
here we're talking about a physical
object we're talking about a rope so
some people say well bill
all you did was replace the word field
with the word thread no
thread is not a field field is a concept
thread is a physical object okay and
that's
that's where people have to learn the
language
okay okay uh so
here's just a brief last uh issue here
i'm going to compare
the electricity of quantum mechanics and
classical mechanics
against the rope model classical and
quantum mechanics they have these
beads flowing from atom to atom under
the rope model what we have is a torsion
of what we call a serpentine all these
atoms or molecules depending on
the context are physically merged
one with the other they form a long
string and they rotate
in situ so when you turn on the
electricity all you're doing is twirling
something
in there it's rotating uh
you know around the axis it's spinning
around the axis
and here's the circuit comparison also
between uh the rope
model and the quantum model okay so the
quantum says look when you
bring down the switch and you create a
connection there or closed circuit
uh what you have is electron beads
flowing and that's what everybody learns
out there
okay 20 21st century uh we changed all
that we're saying okay now
if you look at the bottom right that's a
um an iron
uh atom okay so we have an atom there
and that atom we're going to join up
with all other atoms there's your atom
okay
we're gonna merge them they're gonna
blend with all other atoms okay
and we're gonna form a long uh thread
or wire of iron okay that's gonna be our
model
that's what's inside your cables we're
gonna assume it's all iron okay
just for the ease of explanation of the
mechanism and then what's going to
happen that iron
uh all those iron molecules that are
stretched out in this
long string they spin in situ and so
when you
uh bring down the switch and create a
closed circuit
what you're doing is torquing the entire
snake that's rolling around from head to
tail okay
and of course it goes in both directions
so that's why
there is no delay uh the one one end of
the uh circuit is not waiting for the
little ball to reach there and say well
when is that ball gonna reach here
i know in the case of the rope model uh
the snake
turns inside out or you know
it turns on itself from beginning to end
from head to toe and from toe to head in
both directions okay so it's
there's no delay okay so uh you can see
the differences between
that and uh quantum mechanics what we
propose what's the issue the issue is
when we come to gravity because quantum
has no
explanation for gravity at all okay
the gravity theory is uh general
relativity and not not special by the
way special relativity is gravity less
it's a flat
flat universe flat world okay flat land
okay there's no gravity you can't fall
down in flat land okay
you can only fall sideways so there's no
gravity in flatland so when we're
talking about gravity we're talking
about general relativity okay
but what you have is that quantum
mechanics has no explanation for gravity
okay and so what you'll see out there
is the following you'll see the standard
model the standard model
it looks like this and sometimes you
know they put the uh
the graviton which is the particle of
gravity that mediates
the gravitational force but they say
it's a hypothetical
particle hypothetical graviton and most
most standard models don't even include
it because
they don't want to embarrass themselves
they say well here we are all these
years we still haven't found the
graviton
okay they found the higgs particle of
mass they found all the others but they
can't
figure out you know how this graviton
particle works what does it do what's
its purpose
and uh let me tell you what the problem
is there again and it's
uh more or less like this
this is the explanation okay or the
the objection to the uh graviton the
standard model is inherently
an incomplete theory okay they they
conceive this
there are fun and remember niels bohr
said it was a complete theory so did
heisenberg these people are saying today
well
not true einstein was right it's not a
complete theory which is what einstein
was criticizing about
you know uh quantum mechanics that it
was it wrote a paper in 1935 saints
incomplete theory
there are fundamental physical phenomena
in nature that the standard model does
not adequately adequately explain
gravity first one on the list the
standard model does not explain gravity
straightforward period we're done the
approach of
simply adding a graviton to the standard
model does not recreate what is observed
experimentally without other
modifications
moreover the standard model is widely
considered to be incompatible with the
most successful theory of gravity today
general relativity
okay so that in a nutshell tells you
something about
gravity as far as quantum mechanics is
concerned it has no
answer to gravity okay so what are they
doing
just so you can see one of the big
problems that they have in quantum
mechanics
here you have a feynman diagram and
you can take time forward or like they
do in quantum physics uh
they take time backwards what they have
is two electrons are moving and they
throw
a photon at each other or one throws it
at the other because it can only go one
way
remember all these waves and particles
they only move one way but that's how
they interact and so they say look if
you have two electrons they're moving
parallel to each other or more or less
parallel
and one throws a photon on the other
it'll move that one away
okay we all understand it because it's a
push force now how do we do
pull okay that's where we have a little
bit of problem okay
and here you have what strength theory
proposes for the graviton and says look
it's it's one of these closed loops
uh that uh strings that um
that forms what we call the graviton so
the graviton is really a particle but
it's made out of vibrating
one-dimensional strings
okay fine no problem please explain with
your graviton your
your string like graviton please explain
pull i want i want you to explain the
the only force that mathematical physics
to this state has been unable to explain
and that is the force of pull
so you know the all these um
mathematical physics whether you talk
about gravity uh
i'm sorry general relativity or quantum
mechanics
you're always talking about push it's
all pressure it's all um
you know it's all pushing there is no
pull
so half the forces of the universe are
missing in mathematical physics
and they've been missing for 10 000
years because what they can never
explain with discrete particles is pull
even even in the case of general
relativity where you have
you know the um uh the depression
in the uh space-time canvas the fishnet
trampoline whatever you want to call it
when you have that depression
why does the ball fall down why does it
fall upwards
and you say well it follows the contour
of
space time but then you're introducing
gravity you're saying it falls because
of gravity why don't they make the
canvas
upwards so that people are aware of that
see if they made it if
they always drew it upwards then people
say oh that's counters too
intuitive you mean here's this ball
rolling i can understand it going
down into the hole at the bottom
but now you put the hole in reverse and
the hole is upwards
you know like imagine uh a hole inside a
mountain
do balls travel up that hole i mean if
you make a hole in the ground yeah you
can you know
you can play golf the ball will fall in
the hole
but hopefully you don't have a field
where all the holes are
in the ceiling and you play golf and try
to get the ball to fall inside the hole
you know you're standing upside down
with your feet magnetized uh
against the uh the ceiling and you hit
the ball it's always gonna fall down
it's never gonna fall into the hole
and so this is the issue what they
cannot explain is the force of pull even
in general relativity no matter how they
twist and turn it
so all they can do is treat it
mathematically okay and this is the
issue the issue is they're just going to
do math
okay um so one of the
things that they tried to do was
to incorporate gravity
from general relativity blended somehow
with gravity in quantum mechanics which
has never been defined
okay they don't have a mechanism for
gravity and quantum mechanics but they
say look we have this graviton particle
and maybe somehow we can merge these two
theories
general relativity and quantum mechanics
find some commonality
not in physics in mathematics they're
going to do equations they're going to
try to
equate the equations or somehow figure
out how the equation of one
discipline matches the equations of
another discipline
that's what strength theory is all about
they're going to try to get these
equations to
somehow be compatible with each other
okay so uh
what is uh and what the best way to do
it with is with a black hole because the
black hole
of general relativity is a good place
where you can start playing with
particles remember you have a
singularity at a center well that sounds
pretty much like the point particle
which is also zero dimensional nothing
okay and then what happens to particles
that fall into the black hole for
example
stephen hawking demonstrated that you
have this hawking radiation particles
coming out of the black hole
which supposedly nothing comes out of a
black hole well stephen hawking says
you're wrong
they do he proved it okay so they have
these particles coming out of the bicone
going in
and there's this uh thing going on at
the edge
of the black hole and they say okay
maybe by studying that
we can get an idea of how gravity can be
merged from quantum mechanics can be
merged with gravity from general
relativity
that's the idea of string theory that's
that's the overall structure or the
goal or the foundation of string theory
okay so what do we get from uh
mr hawking well he says uh the horizon
is a boundary defined by
like light like geodesics okay it is
those light rays that are just barely
unable to escape
if neighboring geodesics start moving
towards each other they eventually
collide at which point their extension
is inside the black hole these things
extend inside the black hole the
geodesics okay that's what a black hole
is made out of
according to these people so the
geodesics are
are always moving apart and the number
of geodesics which generate the boundary
the area of the horizon the event
horizon right always increases
okay as more junk falls in you know you
have this
uh event horizon which expands why
because you have more mass and the
radius of the event horizon is a
function of how much mass
the black hole has okay that's
essentially the notion here okay
and hawking result hawking's result was
called the second law of black
hole thermodynamics okay because they're
they're going to be saying the following
they're going to say that if a particle
falls into a black hole
or what happens to a particle well the
particle disappears it gets crushed out
of existence the
the matter of the particle gets crushed
out of existence
but not the information the information
still remains
floating around inside the black hole
whatever that means to you okay
in other words the the charge the mass
all this stuff is still floating around
in there the momentum right all this
is still inside the black hole in the in
the uh
volume constrained by the
event horizon which is this membrane for
lack of a
different word that somehow encapsulates
the singularity
okay so you have a singular in the
center you have this region of influence
which is like a campfire you know you
can
get close to the campfire it's too hot
you can further you go out well the
less heat you get and that region of
influence that region of heat
that's what's going to be called the
event horizon yeah that the boundary
and any particle that falls in there the
particle gets crushed out of existence
but the information remains
and you say well who cares bill if you
know i can't see it
because i can't appear inside the black
hole i don't know what's going on inside
there so
it's like okay and but they say that you
can
determine all the all that information
that was that is floating in there for
that particle
is mapped at the surface of the black
hole it's mapped
it's represented at the event horizon
so you have a 2d surface as they call it
you know that which is this event
horizon a perfect sphere
you would think right and it contains
the information
of the volume that it encapsulates
that's why it's called uh that's why
they've gone into how
holographic universe and that's why they
talk about holograms
in the uh context of black holes and
string theory
the holographic uh notion uh principle
and universe all that has a lot to do
with string theory
because they say look if we can find a
relation
between the surface and the volume if
the mapping of the volume is on the
surface right if you can map it on the
surface if you can represent it at the
surface
by studying a surface you can tell
what's going on
inside a black hole without having to
travel into one
okay so uh that's why all these
blackboard guys go in there and play
around with the equations they
figure out integrals and they calculate
derivatives
why because they're toying around with
what happens to a particle
when it falls back and forth because
some particles come out some particles
go in so they analyze all these
parameters
and they play around with equations okay
so it developed a um a cottage industry
for the new wave of mathematicians
because they say look
in quantum we're at a dead end where we
found a wall you know we can't go
further in quantum because like
mr boer said it's a complete theory as
complete as it can be and it's not
complete so what's missing well we need
to get gravity and gravity is outside
the bounds of
quantum so we have to move into strength
theory to analyze it
are they going to give you a physical
interpretation no they're going to give
you a mathematical
interpretation they're trying to unify
the equations
because they say this one describes uh
gravity at uh in general relativity in
this other one describes
uh string theory right describes uh
gravity at the quantum level okay but
for that you have to consider not one
zero dimensional points you have to
consider one-dimensional strings okay so
now that's that's where the change came
in
started around 1970s the late 60s
beginning of the 70s
and that's been 50 years and so this
thing has been ballooning
ever since and part of it is because the
new breeds coming you know into college
what else are they going to do well
they're going to play with the math
related to
black holes particles at the edge of a
black hole
what is a black hole well black hole is
all gravity that's all black hole
deals with gravity and mass mass and
gravity that's uh 99.99 of what a black
hole is
so if if that's been proven and they've
seen them out there in the sky
with their telescopes et cetera et
cetera and they took pictures of them
right
won the nobel prize couple years ago uh
then that's where you got to go you got
to go inside the black hole and study
particles in there
and what do you do you play around with
the math and it gives you you know a lot
gives you something to do
in your spare time okay so um
what are they saying uh what is gravity
according to general relativity well
here
i'll give you an analogy okay and it's
uh imagine that uh you see the earth the
earth
has all these parallels and uh meridians
well the meridians meet at the uh
north pole right because they get curved
and they get curved inwards on a globe
okay so what happens if we put uh two
elephants right
and we run them along these uh what they
call geodesics
well they're gonna crash at some point
they're gonna bump into each other as
they approach
the north pole it's obvious right
because the the path their paths are
curved
and so they're going to meet each other
whether they like it or not they're
going to you know they're going to touch
each other
and here comes the astounding conclusion
of the mathematician they said
that's gravity the reason the elephants
came together
is because of gravity what's gravity
it's geodesics
curved geodesics which do not run
parallel all the way to infinity
they meet they meet because the surface
that you're analyzing of whatever object
that celestial object
is spherical it's curved so if it's
curved
the geodesics point inwards they touch
and whatever runs along those geodesics
comes together let me give you an
analogy
maybe it'll help help you visualize this
okay
see if see if this makes sense to you
your friend and you
you know he starts from his house you
start from your house and you
go along the path he goes through the
forest you go through the city right it
turns out your paths
are curved and they meet at the
waterfall and it turns out yeah when
you both reach the waterfall you meet
the other guy and you bump into hey joe
you're here huh
did you get closer to your friend to joe
did you get closer to him because
there's a gravitational attraction
or because the paths are curved
that's what these people are saying if
people are saying that it's geodesics
tells you
that space is curved and it explains
gravity because you come
closer to the other fellow because you
know the
geodesics the curved itineraries they
meet
on a curved surface that's their
argument and here let me
rub that in a little bit he got a little
gift here
let's remove one of the elephants okay
and this time
uh we have only one elephant okay and
he's gonna run all by himself
on a geodesic now is he approaching the
other geodesic
because the past is current i mean is he
being attracted by the geodesic by an
itinerary
is this what what we should conclude
here
you see what's happening uh the elephant
is coming closer to the other jail does
it we got rid of the other elephant
there's no
matter all we have is an itinerary it's
uh he approaches the other
itinerary is what pulled them there
is it just the fact that the two
itineraries are curved
in fact i could remove uh all the
elephants out of there and the question
is whether you know
uh two itineraries that meet
uh represent gravitational attraction
this is what these people are saying
they're into such abstractions that you
would believe
and they can do this because they they
just do math when you ask them for the
physical interpretation they say i'll go
to the other side of campus to
the philosophers of science that they do
that stuff so why did they try to give a
physical interpretation to their
equations
if that's philosophy why do they do
philosophy in mathematical physics
and i'll tell you why because otherwise
their math is irrelevant because if they
cannot provide a physical mechanism for
how this universe works
their math is irrelevant so they have to
extrapolate it into physics and say
well this is the description we've got
and obviously
you know all these geodesics meet and
that's gravity because the equation says
so
so it's um gravity is two itineraries
that attract each other or that somehow
meet or whatever
okay what happens with a particle
because we have to unite
uh particles from quantum mechanics with
general relativities
geodesics right so what happens when a
particle falls into a black hole
okay so um ah got the wrong one hold it
let me
think i got the wrong one or did i get
the right one no i got the right one
okay so you have the particle falling
into the black hole okay and what
happens there
what happens is that that projection is
onto the surface of the black hole
okay so even though the particle
disappeared from a
structural point of view its ghost
its spirit remains and it's reflected
onto the surface so the surface carries
the information
of the particle that was annihilated by
falling into the black hole okay
so all you have to do is study all the
uh particles
that form the horizon the event horizon
the
boundary of the black hole okay that's
all you need to study and then how do
you study them well you
do equations you do uh integrals you do
uh derivatives
you know again cottage industry has
developed around this and people have a
lot of work to do because
there's a lot of stuff to calculate
there and so they're all into this world
they're not worried about the physical
interpretation they're just worried
about getting the math right
they want the equation that gives them
the gut the grand unified theory or the
toe the
theory of everything what is a theory
theory is an explanation
not in math phys mathematical physics a
theory is a description of mathematical
description
explanations that's on the other side of
campus so when people you know nobody
cares about math so people just say well
tell me what gravity is and they say
well you got to take math to understand
okay so that's the answer you get okay
so uh what did uh mr um
uh uh mr
uh uh i was thinking of maradona
i wanted mr maldasena
come up with what did he provide to this
well first let me look at this
uh here you can see that each patch
on the surface of a black hole you know
you can take a plank area which is a
very tiny tiny tiny the
thing the tiniest thing you can imagine
so to speak okay
and you have what do they talk about
they talk about these areas representing
entropy
representing information and uh
this sort of thing they say the entropy
of a black hole is proportional to the
number of plank areas that it would take
to cover the black holes event horizon
okay and so um again what did uh mr
maldasena contribute to this
if i can find it here
let me get this thing up here okay and
uh
this is his conjecture essentially okay
and it has to do again with equations it
has to do with um
it has to do with um you know just
calculating things it doesn't have
anything really to do with
the physicality he's not going to give
you a physical interpretation he's just
going to give you a mathematical
description and essentially what he's
saying is you know that the math that
describes the behavior of particles
that interact weekly weekly you know on
the surface of uh black hole
more or less approximates the math um of
a strongly interacting particles
described in quantum field theory
okay so so essentially this this is his
argument this is what he contributed
and this created a can of worms that the
mathematicians are still
trying to elucidate okay so this is this
is what his contribution is for this you
won a lot of those
prizes and so on okay and uh
so it gives you this holographic black
hole
so to speak okay which looks more or
less like this says that
the surface essentially contains the
information that's inside the black hole
that's it now why don't i go in more
detail in all this
i mean first because i spend all year on
it but
more importantly than that it's
irrelevant all of this is irrelevant it
has nothing to do with physics nothing
to do with science
and that's why i'm suggesting that you
consider very well
what your taxes are used for especially
in relation to the ias the institute of
advanced study okay and let me tell you
why it's irrelevant
because there's no physicality to this
it's all abstraction
let's see what the rope model proposes
first for gravity okay
so that you have something to compare it
against and here's a simple
mother nature's universe very simple all
atoms are interconnected so we have a
cylinder
and we have six atoms on a cube one atom
on the cylinder you can see what's
happening here as
the distance between them decreases in
other words uh if you apply newton's
equation which is
uh tested quite largely here on earth at
least okay
um as the cylinder approaches the cube
what you see is the
ropes that interconnect all those atoms
they fan out
that's it that's how simple mother
nature uh
is and how she does her daily work of
gravity and there you see when they're
further apart
okay there is no action at a distance
that you just cannot see the mediator or
touch it okay and i'll get to that in a
second
but when they're further apart okay uh
gravity is weak why because all the uh
you're you're pulling almost on a single
coaxial
all the ropes come together you know at
great distances like one star from
another
the only reason you see only a little
dot in the sky is all those ropes have
become you know come together and form
the single coaxial
what happens when two objects approach
each other like you know maybe a comet
approaches the earth or an asteroid or
whatever
well then you get the what you see in
the second uh group there
the ropes fan out closer they are more
the more the ropes fan out
and yeah that explains gravity that
explains the acceleration of gravity
here you have
another version of that okay just so
that
you are familiar with the mechanism that
we're proposing here's an astronaut
falling to earth and the closer he gets
the more the ropes
every atom in his body is connected to
every atom on earth i didn't draw them
all by the way and
as he falls okay the ropes fan out for
every location
that he has with respect to the center
of the earth
he has a different weight you have uh
relativists
who tell you that uh if the sun were to
disappear would take eight minutes
for we for us to find out because uh
nothing can travel faster than light and
light takes eight minutes
uh to reach us from the sun so gravity
cannot travel faster than
light so if the sun were to disappear
like zeus or god or
the devil made it disappear you wouldn't
find out about it
until eight minutes later well that's
impossible because
it violates everything we know that
we've confirmed out there
and that is that you have weight for
every step you take an astronaut has
weight for every step he takes
in the direction of the earth so for
every location he's got a different
weight he just has to move
one millimeter forward he's already got
a different weight how can you explain
that well with the rope model you can
explain because now the number of ropes
is different
instantly as soon as you move to that
new location you have a new set of ropes
why because they they were all on the
same axis
now they suddenly separate and then they
separate some more and then they
separate some more and
the ropes in between keep getting out of
alignment they're not on the same axis
so you have more effective ropes as we
call them and that explains
uh not only the acceleration of gravity
it explains why if the sun
if god came in there and made the sun
disappear he would fly out of there
instantaneously just like if you're
climbing
uh a mountain and you're hanging from
from a guy you know he's he's up there
and you're hanging he cuts the rope
it doesn't take eight minutes for you to
receive the information you will fall
instantaneously
that's how it works uh with a rope model
okay
so why does the earth go around the sun
something that uh
general relativity cannot explain why
can they explain it because they use
space time
space time is a concept we have to
explain why the earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system
are they saying there's a warped time
that comes in contact with the skin
of the earth that's why the earth cannot
fly out because there's a
warped wall of time under the rope model
very simple
the sun pearls the earth around from
the ropes every atom in the earth is
connected to every atom
that forms the sun and what happens is
that
space is nothing absolutely nothing
meaning it has no shape that's the
definition of space of vacuum
that which has no shape and so there's
nothing there as far as uh
space is concerned so the earth has
nothing to rub its elbow against
there is no friction between earth and
space
and so yeah there's nothing to stop the
earth from floating around the sun
forever there's uh obviously some
changes gravitational
uh changes in the sense that there are
other planets are pulling on the earth
the moon also pulls uh there's a
rotation there's lots of movement
in there and that also makes sure that
the earth
doesn't fly forever around the sun in
the same way
sometimes it changes its magnetic field
sometimes it might change its
orientation given millions of years etc
etc okay
okay and uh so why haven't they
discovered what's the problem with this
people say well i've got a problem with
your rope hypothesis they caught theater
you know it's a hypothesis
okay it's known as a hypothesis what is
a hypothesis an assumption
okay so you make an assumption and with
that assumption you explain
a mechanism that's what a hypothesis is
so what happens um
some people say well i can't see the
rope you know when i drop a pencil
here i'm going to drop this okay okay
when i let go of it foster the floor and
we know that you can do the experiment
at home always in
the presence of a trained relativist and
if you let go of a pencil a pen a spoon
the baby whatever always falls to the
floor
okay no exceptions unless there's some
other factor out there you know
influencing
your experiment otherwise it falls to
the floor and the question is you know
when you look at this you say well i
don't see anything i can't touch
anything other than the air right i
don't see anything here in fact you can
do this in a vacuum it'll do the same
thing like they did it on the moon you
know feather with a hammer
okay so there's nothing there and you
say so bill where's this famous
rope of yours when we need it okay and
so uh
let's bring mr alkalili jim alcalee
which we talked about a couple weeks ago
and he says the following he says you
put this guy over here
he says the following he says uh imagine
i'm the sun
and this tennis ball is the earth in
orbit around me
okay newton's laws uh can describe very
precisely the path the earth takes
around the sun
in terms of the mutual gravitational
attraction between two bodies okay great
but what newton can't explain okay
what newton can't explain is what
connects them
looking for a connection physical
connection in reality of course there is
no invisible string between the earth
and the sun holding the two together
there's just empty space a complete void
and yet according to newton the earth
and the sun pull on each other
instantaneously across a fast distance
how can gravity
uh can gravity act in this way when
there's nothing to connect it or
transmit it
so how did mr alkalini and his
colleagues how did they conclude that
there is
nothing binding the earth with the sun
where did they get this and where does
everybody get this idea well you know i
can't touch
or see anything between the pencil and
the floor so there's obviously
nothing there this is what prevented all
these people from
uh visualizing the mechanism as
prevented people from
ever discovering the rope model of light
okay
and gravity and so uh we have to start
at the beginning
and good place to start is with the
foundations of physics
physics cannot be done without an object
it's called the golden principle of
physics
started in the 21st century golden
principle says you can't do physics
without an object
if you erase all matter from the
universe there's nothing there no shapes
okay nothing there no no structure
nothing
then what is what is happening what are
you visualizing what can you measure
what what physics is there without
objects so the first principle the
golden principle is that you need an
object to do physics
and the next step is to define what an
object is
for the purposes of physics all these
people have said well what an object is
is see and touch whatever you can see
whatever you can touch
so they say let's go to the lab let's
see what we can see let's see what we
can touch
and it turns out they can't see or touch
the mediator of light
the mediator of gravity the mediator of
magnetism
they can't touch or see any of those so
they never learn the lesson after 10 000
years
and so we have to put this up here okay
here it is
okay what is an object an object is that
which has shape
not that which you can see or touch you
can't see the air but hopefully the air
is made out of
atoms molecules right uh is an atom an
object
i think a lot of people would say it is
it's an object you know you might talk
about uh
subatomic particles but hopefully an
atom that people say is is an object in
fact
under string theory all particles are
black holes
yeah just like you heard particle is a
black hole and when you look at the
surface
of a uh say a proton
what you're looking at is the surface of
the black hole contained within it in
other words you're looking at the
you're looking at the um what is it
at the surface of the event horizon of
the proton
and the volume contained and it contains
the information of the volume that's
inside
that membrane or that whatever that's
that perimeter yeah so every particle is
a black hole that's another reason
string theory likes this stuff because
they can now talk about black holes
and in the context of particles okay you
see where this has gone
anyways the point here is you can't
touch a tri bar because there's no such
monster you can touch the paper you can
touch the ink
maybe the pixel on the screen but you
certainly cannot touch a tri bar
or a circle or any of those you can't
touch snow white you can touch the the
ink
or the paint or whatever but you can't
touch snow white and likewise you can't
see the air okay so so are those not
objects no they're objects because they
have shape
two-dimensional objects are objects
three-dimensional objects are objects
because they have shape they all
have shape they have the universal
property that all objects have which is
shape
once you define it the shape well then a
lot of people have a lot of problems
because now you know you
you a lot of things like space time zero
dimensional particles
black holes zero dimensional black holes
which are surrounded by the concept
known as event horizon which is the
region of influence of a singularity
which is a concept
all that is washed away there is no such
thing as a black hole and that's why
strength theory is just
spinning its wheels because all they're
doing is analyzing stuff that has no
reality whatsoever or has any
possibility of being
primarily because they never defined the
qualitative terms
necessary to begin their investigation
they can do the math but based on
something that's real
but when they do when they develop uh
integrals and
and uh do you know calculate derivatives
on stuff that has no chance whatsoever
of having any reality any any existence
any actuality
then what are they doing they're
spinning their wheels and that's what
you're paying for when you
your tax dollars end up at the ias
okay uh dark matter the last one here
just so uh we finish up
they can't answer what dark matter is
they're investigating this dark matter
thingy okay
so what is dark matter very quickly uh
when you have um a galaxy that rotates
okay what they found
is that most if not all i think at least
most spiral galaxies
um the stars on the outside on the
perimeter of the galaxy
move just as fast or faster than the
stars on the inside that's what that
graph shows there okay
so you can see uh there's a curve that
goes downwards another curve that goes
upwards the one that goes upwards
is the actual the one they verified the
other one is the one they
calculated but then calculation doesn't
match reality so they said okay
why doesn't it match and they fixed it
they fixed everything like they do every
time they fix it only through mass and
gravity that's the only thing a
mathematician
understands he only understands math
mass and gravity
so they say what if we sprinkle all
these kilograms over here
well yeah then then you can make an
ad-hoc
solution to this by saying well if we
add all this mass out here on the
outside i don't know why all this
dark stuff is on the outside but they
just put it on the outside by hand
and they say well if we put all these
kilograms here then we can explain why a
galaxy rotates like this called a
gravity rotational problem okay so they
fix the problem
artificially by putting kilograms here
great and so now they're looking for
these dark kilograms these
invisible dark concepts and they're
trying to reproduce them at the lhc at
the large having collider
here in geneva okay and so yeah uh
a little bit of a problem because if
there is no such thing as dark matter
which they claim they have proven
already
to exist uh there is no such thing as
dark matter then all the equations all
the work that they're doing at the lhc
define dark matter
all that work is in vain these people
are working on stuff that has no reality
whatsoever they're
in left field working who knows and what
so how do we explain it under the rope
model
very easy it's baby stuff it's for
kindergartner so i don't want to offend
your intelligence
by showing you this but mother nature is
a very simple woman
she only deals with rocks i mean
what is a planet a rock what is mars
that's a rock and so when you have two
rocks like i don't know mars and
one of its moons focus or damas
you only have two stones how difficult
can it be do we need to know
trigonometry for this do we need to know
geometry for this
so no the way it works is that when a
galaxy rotates okay
all atoms are interconnected means all
stars are physically
interconnected so a um a galaxy rotates
like a carousel
like uh you know the stars on the
outside rotate more or less
at the same speed of the ones on the
inside maybe faster maybe slower for
different reasons because they're also
tugged by other stars
but the point here is that if you have a
physical connection between all stars
now you can explain why a galaxy rotates
almost as a single piece
as a if if it were a disk
okay so it's very simple oh we have to
get rid of this dark matter nonsense and
simply concentrate on the physicality
and the fact that all atoms are
interconnected then there's a piece of
cake then you don't have to
ponder about uh what i explained the
other day monde uh the
uh modified newtonian uh
uh what is it the the equation uh for
vermont uh or or uh or the um
or dark matter you don't need any of
that because all those are mathematical
fixes they're ad hoc fixes to make the
equations match what they see out there
that's how they proved
the existence of dark matter they simply
put in uh
a factor in their variable to make
uh the equations match observation
that's what they did and we don't need
any of that all we need to say is look
let's make it a qualitative assumption
all atoms are interconnected physically
interconnected meaning
all stars are physically interconnected
and then the whole thing rotates like a
single carousel
we're done that's how simple it is
that's how simple it was all these years
and these people can keep doing math all
the way to kingdom come you know
okay uh just uh some of the comments
from people who do not agree with
mr maldisana and his strength theorists
okay here's a
probably the first uh vocal person his
name is sheldon glassow he's a nobel
prize winner
and he says glacier is one of the
remaining phenomenologists at harvard
phenomenologist as a person what who
wants to use his hands
and eyes he believes in
experiments okay he said what experiment
can you run with string theory that's
his main objection to it and he says
strength theory is a discipline distinct
from physics
he puts it outside the bounds of physics
you may call it a tumor
if you will
love that uh string theory is a tumor
but he continues
and he tells you why string theory is
dangerous and maybe why you should not
contribute to the ias and here's his
comment he says the following
he says the lhe is smashing particles to
discover the nature of the subatomic
world
who will be interested in trying to fit
these discoveries into the theory
it will be people like me except we may
be dead by then
or if not will be rather old or it will
be the young theoretical physicists
but the young theoretical physicists are
doing string theory
and they ain't interested in the results
of the experiments not now and not then
so who's going to be there to continue
the role of building a better theory of
particle physics
particle physics and yeah uh
i feel for for uh mr uh glashaw
because he sees that all the work of all
these accelerators is going down the
drain because
these folks are staying in the in their
uh little houses doing maybe uh
home office and all they're doing is
calculations and their calculations are
just
to figure out what the relationship is
between particles and a black hole may
name
string theory that's where all the
effort is going you're having more and
more strength theories today
why because they've given up on quantum
mechanics on the explanations
that quantum mechanics uh has not
addressed and they feel they have the
sense this uh
intuition that strength theory is the
way to go that's because you have to
somehow unite these two disciplines
general relativity and
quantum mechanics and you can't do it
with one or the other you need both
to get the gut to toe okay and he's not
the only one who
complains there's another vocal uh
individual against string theorists
so you keep these people in mind this is
mr um peter voight uh white i think his
name is pronounced
uh valuing what's his uh complaint he
wrote a book not even wrong and no i
didn't turn the book around that's
that is the cover of the book valuing
mathematical elegance over empirical
evidence
he says you need empirical you need
empiricism lacks testable predictions
and is promoted with public money
despite its failure so far
okay so again where are you gonna put
your dollars you're gonna put him in
strength here you're gonna
support the ias the institute of
advanced study in princeton
which is the number one probably uh
think tank for strength theory in the
world okay
excessive media and uh mr malacena works
here okay
excessive media attention and funding of
this one particular mainstream endeavor
which he considers speculative risk
overwhelming public faith in the freedom
of scientific research
he's worried that all these guys are
going to take over
or like someone said you know the uh
theory the old theories die when their
proponents die and the new generation
prevents new theories
and they don't follow their professors
and it's like a massive movement and a
grassroots movement and the final person
i'm going to mention here
and it's this lady and her name is
sabine
hawsenfelder and she writes a book lost
in math
and she's a research fellow specializing
in quantum gravity and modifications to
the general
theory of relativity at frankfurt
institute of advanced studies
up here a couple miles north of where i
live and um
her complaint is there is no
observational evidence again all these
people have
similar arguments and area starved of
data that's what she thinks of strength
theory
and how can non-empirical arguments
increase confidence in a theory
and again i have a problem with that as
well
with what she's saying because
empiricism
you cannot empiricize the mediator
of light gravity or magnetism you cannot
touch or see
the only way to uh approach the problem
is
visualizing in order to visualize what
can you visualize you need to visualize
objects you can't do physics without an
object so you need
to imagine how mother nature is doing
her work
for this you need no math mathematics
equations whatsoever mother nature does
not use equations she uses objects
and she doesn't move concepts around
like all these people she moves objects
some of those objects are invisible and
intangible like the mediator of light
and gravity and magnetism cetera
and so you're not going to find you're
not going to discover them by going to
the lab you're not going to
discover them through see and touch to
an experiment
the only way is to sit back drink a beer
visualize
visualize the mechanism for that you
need
objects you need something some
structure some entity
okay okay and the reason i mentioned
this lady i'll be talking about her
in the next uh class okay next nice
lecture